Let's talk about wasteful spending.
I should say at the outset,
that this is an understandably contentious issue.
As you can see here,
the IOM has identified sources of waste,
and says that in aggregate they account for around 30% of all U.S. health care spending.
A ratio that has remained unchanged for decades.
The widely respected journal Health Affairs,
breaks wasteful spending into multiple categories.
First, are failures of care delivery.
This refers to poor execution or failure to adopt best practices,
such as for effective preventive care or patient safety.
Second, our failures of care coordination.
This means fragmented and disjointed care,
such as when patients move from one care setting to another called transitions of care.
Peer coordination turns out to be a major use case for health informatics.
Third, is over treatment.
Here that ignores scientific evidence.
This complex area includes defensive medicine done to avoid lawsuits.
As well as the use of higher price services that have negligible or
no health benefits over less expensive alternatives.
This is another major use case for informatics.
Specifically, clinical decision support.
You should read the Health Affairs paper for a more detailed discussion.
Fourth, is administrative complexity.
This is excess spending because payers our regulatory agencies create
inefficient or flawed rules and overly bureaucratic procedures.
As I alluded to earlier,
I believe the multiplicity of insurance plans and
government programs here in the US adds to these costs.
Fifth, is pricing failure.
This is when the price of a service exceeds that found in
a properly functioning marketplace which would expect to be
equal to the actual costs of production plus a reasonable profit.
For example, here in the US,
pharmaceutical costs are significantly higher than in other countries.
Surprisingly by law, Medicare is prohibited from
negotiating with pharmaceutical companies to get the best possible prices.
Last, are fraud and abuse.
In addition to the cost of the fraud itself.
This includes the cost of additional inspections and regulations to catch wrongdoing.